[Musik]
mein name ist oberst bernhard schuler ob
ich bin der kommandant von mega party in
wien 2 unsere heutige truppenübung
findet am truppenübungsplatz
bruckneudorf
im burgenland statt ihm heuer drei
schwerpunkte gesetzt fortsetzen der
schießausbildung stimme aber 77 und
pistole 80 der zweite punkt ist gefechts
dienst zum thema kontrolle von personen
und kfz im gelände und entlang von
strassen und drittens trainieren wir das
durchsuchen von gelände abschnitten das
dient einerseits im stellen bewaffnete
personen kann aber auch angewendet
werden wenn es dem auffinden vermisster
personen in zusammenarbeit mit behörden
dient
die einzige chance
[Musik]
foto privat
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dies ist meine letzte truppenübung als
kommandant dieses herausstehenden
verbandes und werde am ende dieser übung
das command nachfolger übergeben
getreu unserem motto stets bereit sind
wir fit für die zukunft
es bedarf aber weiteren intensiven
trainings unser niveau zu halten dazu
wünsche ich dem verband alles alles gute
für die zukunft
[Musik]
[Applaus]